Hello, Bay Area Beautiful Nerds. Join me Monday evening November 3rd at the Alamo Draft House in the Mission in San Francisco for a special screening of the brilliant documentary, Drop Dead City, followed by a Q&A with me and the filmmakers. If it sounds familiar, Drop Dead City is the movie that Elliot and I covered a few weeks ago as part of our Power Broker series. Now, I don't do that many live events these days, so I hope you'll come hang out with me at the movies,
on Monday, November 3rd. Tickets are cheap. They're under 13 bucks. Sign up for your seat using the event link in the show notes or on our website, 99PI.org. This is the 99% of visible breakdown of the Constitution. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elizabeth Jeff. Today we are finishing up our discussion of Article 1, which established the legislative branch of the federal government. Our special guests for this, This episode is Elizabeth Warren, the senior Democratic senator from Massachusetts. But first, Elizabeth Joe and I are going to spend some more time going through Article 1. There is so much to cover in this part of the Constitution.
Last time, we talked about the first seven sections, which described the houses of Congress, who gets to be a member of the House and the Senate, how bills become federal law, and which chamber plays which role in the process of impeachment. And in this episode, we're going to focus more on the back half of Article 1. which describes the powers of Congress. So, where do you want to start? All right. Well, I think a useful way to think about the remainder of Article 1 is this.
We can talk about what Congress can do, what Congress is prohibited from doing, and then what the states are prohibited from doing. And I thought we'd also talk about two powers of Congress that are important but non-obvious even after we talk about Article 1. Okay. All right. Let's do it. So the remainder of Article 1 begins with Section 8.
And so Section 8 is very important because it is the Constitution explicitly providing Congress with specific legislative powers. And now one thing to keep in mind, Roman, is that our Constitution isn't the first one that we have. That title belongs to the Articles of Confederation. And the Articles of Confederation imagined a very different structure. There was no federal judiciary, no executive, but there was a Confederation Congress, which did have some familiar powers. It could wage war, it could coin money, and it could set up post offices. Okay.
But importantly, the Confederation Congress had no ability to impose taxes and no ability to regulate commerce at a national level. So those two missing powers alone are some pretty major limitations. Yeah, you can't raise your. revenue for the federal government, and you can't treat the entire country as one regulated national economy. So our present constitution is a reaction both to what worked and what didn't work in the Articles of Confederation. So what are some of the things that, you know, Congress can now do? Well, just like with the Articles of Confederation, it can declare war, coin money,
and set up post offices. Now it can protect and regulate intellectual property, including patents and copyrights, but maybe most importantly, Section 8 gives Congress the power to regulate interstate commerce. Yeah, that's right. So the power, as described, doesn't say too much. Congress has the ability to regulate commerce with foreign nations and among several states and with the Indian tribes. But there are two developments that can help us understand why the Commerce Clause is so important today. So the easy one is that today, unlike in 1787, say, everything is touched by interstate commerce, right? I mean, the fact that most of our goods are made somewhere else,
in fact, not just within the United States, but around the world, it means that it's pretty easy for Congress to say, we want to regulate something because it has some relationship to interstate commerce. So that's made it a lot different and easy for Congress, just because of the way the world has changed. Yeah, yeah. And as we've seen over the years of doing this show, regulating interstate commerce becomes the pretense for all kinds of other regulation when it comes to states.
Right. And that took a while because over the course of some 80 plus years, the Supreme Court's interpretation of the Commerce Clause is what's important here. It's the Supreme Court that allows Congress through its interpretation of the clause to start using this power in greater and greater ways. And of course, this all began during FDR's time when the Supreme Court faced enormous pressure to let Congress respond to the Great Depression with national regulation. And the commerce power isn't completely limitless, but it's so broad today that it isn't reserved just for regulating actual objects like cans or boxes that cross state lines. There are today literally hundreds, maybe 700 laws that actually mention the Commerce Clause at the federal level. And these are laws that regulate all kinds of different things, the Endangered Species Act, federal criminal law, food, terrorism, even civil rights laws are justified by the Interstate Commerce Clause.
Wow. Wow. So, yeah, it just becomes an outsized source of constitutional authority for Congress to regulate all kinds of things. And so it's not that each of these powers have equal importance. I would say the Commerce Clause has a really outsized importance in terms of Section 8 power. Can you give an example, sort of either in specific or in the abstract, of how the commerce power is used to regulate a thing that isn't boxes and cans going over a border? Sure. So if Congress wants to criminalize something, right? Congress doesn't have sort of broad authority to criminalize whatever they want. That's something that the states can do, but Congress isn't allowed to do that. But they can say, look, we want to prevent firearm violence.
Yeah, funny joke, right? Okay, this is hypothetical science fiction world in which you are. Okay, go ahead. Exactly. So they can do that by simply saying, we want to regulate a certain kind of firearm. You know, people can't, let's say, possess assault weapons. And they can do so by simply pointing to the fact that a firearm, like an assault weapon, is used or made in interstate commerce.
So even though a crime would happen with an assault weapon, let's say, that would happen entirely within a state, what really matters is there's some part of the federal law that specifically refers to interstate commerce. And again, in today's world, that's so easy because almost everything is in some way related to interstate commerce. There are very few things that are entirely originated in one state and then never leave the state, right? So that's an example.
Okay. And so that's commerce. Now, Section 8 also gives Congress the power to lay and collect taxes. and to provide for the common defense and general welfare of the United States. So this means that Congress has the ability to tax and to spend. This is a very important set of powers here, too, because Congress can certainly spend money on the federal government. But it can also offer what's called conditional spending to the states.
In other words, Congress can tell the states, look, if you want these federal funds, you can get them, but only if you abide by certain conditions. Now, the Supreme Court has said that the federal government can't force the states to do things directly, but it's perfectly okay for the federal government to offer federal monies as kind of carrots to change behavior on the part of the states. I don't know, Roman, do you remember no child left behind? I do, yeah. Right. I mean, that was a Bush-era law about, you know, trying to, you know, like give extra money to support education, right?
Right. That's the benevolent description of it. Right. So George W. Bush signs the law in 2002 and no child left behind. That's right. It says, look, states, if you want this money, we want you to change the way that you run schools, right? And there's a condition. The condition is we want you to start testing kids in elementary school regularly. We want to see if they're falling behind in math and reading. And the states had to make sure that the students were proficient under the federal law. That was a big change that happened around the country. That's kind of like if you're of a certain age, you remember just all the time having to take these tests in elementary school. Yeah, yeah. I wish I was, I wish I answered that differently. That was a horrible time. I mean, my kids, like, had to go through different testing, and it was like a whole month
was kind of gone devoted to testing, yeah, yeah. And in 2015, President Obama signed the Every Student Succeeds Act, which watered down some of these requirements, but there still is, nevertheless, a very large role that the federal government plays in education because of Congress's ability to impose conditional spending. Here's another example closer to home. You know how solo drivers of electric cars can use the carpool lanes? We see them all the time, right? Yeah, yeah, that's right. Yeah. So that's part of a 20-year-old federal funding program to encourage people to drive electric vehicles. The law allows the states to permit this kind of even solo driver to use the carpool lane, as long as they're using an
electric vehicle. But Congress this year failed to renew it. So that's the end of the program. And since states depend on federal funding for their roads, they have to comply with the new rules. And that means no more use of the carpool lanes with electric vehicles. Wow. Okay. Yeah. So that's a big part. So you can see how it can be some pretty dramatic changes just depending on whether or not the states who want federal funding. And of course, they always want federal funding. Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course. So that's spending. Not only does Congress have the spending power, it has the taxing power, too. And the important reason behind taxing, remember, the government needs to generate revenue in a dependable way.
All legislation imposing taxes has to originate in the House, the Chamber are most directly accountable to the people. That's in Section 7, actually, of Article 1. But just like with the spending power, the Supreme Court has played a really important role by expansively interpreting Congress. Congress's taxing power. So the idea here is, yes, of course, taxes are usually used to raise revenue for the federal government, but Congress can also impose taxes as a way to regulate behavior. And it is, in fact, the taxing power of Congress that saved Obamacare. Remember that?
Let's talk about that. So remember, the Affordable Care Act, also known as Obamacare, that was challenged in the Supreme Court. and in 2012, the Supreme Court upheld big portions of the Affordable Care Act. Now, remember, in its original form, the Affordable Care Act created a structure where we wanted everybody, both healthy and less healthy, to take part in the insurance market. That's how health insurance works. Now, one way the ACA did that was to require everybody to have health insurance.
Now, if you didn't, for whatever reason, you had to pay a financial penalty. That was called the shared responsibility. payment. This scheme was called the individual mandate, if you'll recall. And so the ACA needed this to work. We got to have everybody, or nearly everybody, to buy health insurance. So was this plan, get insured or pay, was that constitutional? Well, in 2012, the Supreme Court said yes. The individual mandate was a constitutional exercise of Congress's taxing power. So as the Supreme Court interpreted it, the taxing power is very broad. So Congress can use this power.
I mean, it wasn't really interested in raising revenue from this, but they wanted to sway people's behavior. And that was perfectly okay because Congress has such broad taxing ability. So the ACA is still alive after all these years, thanks in part to the taxing power. Interesting. Okay. Cool. All right. Now, section eight ends, right?
I don't think we'll have time to go through every portion, but let's end with something that's important. And that is the necessary and proper clause. Okay. So this gives Congress the power to make all laws which shall be necessary and proper for carrying into execution the foregoing powers. Okay. So this idea of necessary and proper. These are vague terms. Very vague.
Extremely vague. So how does one determine what is necessary or proper? Okay. So the necessary and proper clause, it is kind of strange for that reason. It doesn't seem to specify anything. And you can think of it not as a statement. standalone power for Congress, but actually an extension of the other listed powers in Section 8. So the clause means that, for example, if Congress wants to use its commerce power,
it can use any lawful means they want to exercise the commerce power. The necessary and proper power is almost like an extension of the listed powers in the remainder of Section 8. So think of federal agencies. Like, why do they exist? The Constitution gives Congress the ability to establish the positions of what the Constitution calls federal officers. That's an Article 2. And to ensure that a federal officer, let's say the Secretary of Education, can do his or her duties,
Congress can establish a federal agency to help that officer do the duties under federal law that they're supposed to do. And in fact, in 1979, Congress did exactly that when it created the Department of Education. The necessary and proper clause allows Congress to do that thing, even though there's no specific power to create the Department of Education.
Right. So this is also a reminder that federal agencies are created by Congress. And so can only be modified by Congress and can only be dismantled by Congress. The President of the United States has no unilateral authority to destroy or get rid of a federal agency. That would require lawmaking, and that's an Article I responsibility. Just mentioning that, throwing that out there. For no reason. Interesting.
So there's also a power in Article 1 that is important, but I think pretty non-obvious. So, Roman, what comes to mind when you hear that Congress has the power of the purse? The power of the purse means that they're in charge of what to spend and therefore everything that requires money. Is it somehow controlled by Congress? Yeah, I think that's like the person. typical answer, that Congress has the ability to spend federal money. But where does that come from exactly? Because Section 8 says that Congress can raise revenue through taxing and can spend or provide for the common defense and general welfare of the United States. So it looks like Congress
has the authority to determine what it considers spending for the general welfare of the United States. But what does that mean exactly? Because every year, the president of the United States comes up with a proposed budget. And every year, Congress responds by coming up with appropriations or specifically designated ways to spend money from the Treasury. But the spending clause doesn't explain totally the power of the purse because it tells us that Congress can spend money, but is Congress the only entity that can spend money?
Maybe you could imagine a system in which the president decides to spend some money and Congress decides to spend some money. So the spending clause doesn't really mean that Congress is the exclusive authority for spending. So that means we need to turn somewhere else. And that's outside of Section 8. Section 9 of Article 1 tells us a bunch of things that Congress cannot do. And here's the important language. The Constitution in Section 9 says that no money shall be drawn from the Treasury,
but in consequence of appropriations made by law. So this is interesting because the appropriations clause is not a power, but a limitation. But it's an important one that tells us something. This appropriations clause says that federal funds can't be used unless there is a process of appropriations made by law. Who makes the law? Congress. So you see, the spending power just says that Congress can spend federal money. But the appropriations clause, the one in Section 9, telling us what Congress can't do, actually tells us that it's Congress who's in charge.
Congress is in charge of the spending authority. Congress alone can determine how federal money can be spent, not the president. The executive branch is simply there to disperse those funds, but only Congress decides how those funds should be spent. So the only role in the power of the purse for the president of the United States is the regular process of lawmaking. If Congress sends an appropriations bill to the president, The president can sign it or veto it.
That's all. In other words, the president can spend only what Congress allows the president to spend. So this is pretty important in understanding why shutdowns happen. It's not because of a lack of funds. It's that if there are any parts of the government that didn't receive new funding through a new appropriations bill, then those parts of government shut down. Why? Because they don't have the constitutional authority from Congress to spend that money.
Got it. Okay. Who. Why couldn't they just put this all in? one section. I don't know. Deliberally confusing, I guess. And so the Appropriations Clause isn't the only subject addressed in Section 9. This section lists other actions that Congress can't take. So why don't we talk about the suspension clause? Okay. So this clause says that the privilege of habeas corpus shall not be suspended unless when in cases of rebellion or invasion, the public safety
may require it. So habeas corpus, it's a, you know, seems like a complicated Latin term, it simply means that a person in government custody is trying to challenge the lawfulness of their detention. So a court that decides that the person is not being held lawfully can order the government holding the person to release them. You're not holding this person lawfully. So this is an ancient writ. It goes back to the 12th century. And today, usually, it's used most often by prisoners to challenge their convictions. But historically, the core idea was to challenge the imprisonment of people who had no access to any judicial procedures at all, and perhaps were being held without charges.
Yeah. Now, the clause doesn't say that habeas can't ever be suspended. It only suggests that its availability can be suspended in extraordinary circumstances, which would be like, we are being invaded, or there's a rebellion, or there's some public safety emergency. But, again, where is the clause? The clause is in Article 1, meaning that Congress is supposed to be in charge of suspending habeas.
it's only ever been suspended four times in the past, including early on in the Civil War, but each time there was congressional approval. Got it. I feel like I kind of know the answer to this since it sits in Article 1, not in Article 2, but is this what Trump and ICE are lying on to round up and deport people without trial, the fact that this word invasion or public safety? Yeah, I mean, so you're getting to the strategy, and then the real question is whether that's constitutional.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So the Trump administration, of course, has been aggressively enforcing immigration laws, including taking people off of the streets, detaining them, and then in many cases, rapidly deporting them. The administration has done this to a number of Venezuelan nationals by claiming they are relying on the Alien Enemies Act, which we've discussed in a previous episode. But the Supreme Court has said that these Venezuelan nationals can have access to the courts to challenge the lawfulness of their detentions. and, in fact, other non-citizens who have been detained in this way by the Trump administration have tried to file habeas claims to challenge the lawfulness of their detention. Now, you're right to say that the Trump administration thinks that it has an answer. White House Deputy Chief of Staff Stephen Miller has suggested this year that Trump is
considering suspending the availability of habeas corpus. And the idea here would be that habeas could be suspended or the availability of having access to a court saying, please consider the lawfulness of my detention, that that could be suspended because we are undergoing what the Trump administration calls an invasion. But the location of the suspension clause provides an answer to Mr. Miller. It's in Article 1 as part of a directive to Congress. The president of the United States doesn't have the constitutional authority all by himself to suspend the availability of habeas corpus.
And that's really important because really the question is, Can the president simply detain people without charges or access to the courts on his own say-so? And the availability of habeas corpus says, no, unless we are living through some extraordinary times. For example, the United States itself is threatened in some way, which I don't think we are at the moment. Yeah. But regardless of that, this Congress's duty to determine if there is a case for rebellion or invasion or the public safety may require it, not the president's. That's right. I mean, there is like a little bit of, you know, historical practice, like Lincoln suspended it during the Civil War and Congress kind of approved of it after, but they did approve of it.
So there is a sense in which the presumption is that Congress has to provide their consent, right? And in fact, the text is pretty clear that it's up to Congress and looking at the location of this power. It's for Congress, not the president. Yeah, yeah. Okay. That's a big one. All right. So let's turn to another fun part of Section 9. Section 9, if you'll remember, prohibits federal officers from accepting gifts or amoluments from foreign states unless Congress consent. So you and I talked quite a bit during the first Trump administration about whether or not foreign entities using the Trump Hotel in Washington, D.C., whether that was considered an emolument. There were lawsuits over this. The lawsuits kind of fizzled out after Trump was out of office. But that very very same clause has another element, and the whole clause says, no title of nobility shall be
granted by the United States, and no person holding any office of profit or trust under them shall, without the consent of Congress, accept any title of any kind from any king, prince, or foreign state. So this means that the Constitution bans the federal government from granting hereditary titles to anyone, and that federal officers can't accept a foreign title without Congress's consent. No kings, right? That's why this slogan is so intuitively appealing. It's embedded in our constitutional DNA, right? It's in the actual original document. We want no kings. We want no one with a hereditary title. And it seems kind of quaint today, right? Because who's threatening to give anybody a title of nobility? But titles of nobility were a very big concern at the
founding. Alexander Hamilton wrote in one of the Federalist essays that so long as titles of nobility are excluded. There can never be serious danger that the government will be any other than that of the people. Wow. Can we talk about fun fact? Okay, so please let's do some fun facts. So it's about the missing 13th Amendment, not the one that was adopted during reconstruction, not at all. So in the years leading up to the war of 1812, there were widespread fears of secret foreign influence. So the federalists who favored the British, worried about the Republicans whom they considered influenced by the French. So in 1810, Republican Senator Philip Reed introduced a constitutional amendment, which eventually received the necessary supermajority
approval by Congress that same year. Here's what it says. If any citizen of the United States shall accept, claim, receive, or retain any title of nobility or honor, such person shall cease to be a citizen of the United States. Whoa. So that goes so much farther than the nobility clause in Article 1. It says no one, no one, period, can accept a title of nobility.
Congress can't even remove the ban by consenting and you lose your citizenship. Now here's the thing, Roman. Twelve states did, in fact, ratify this over the next four years, but then the movement kind of lost steam. But then there was apparently some confusion at the time as to whether it became part
of the Constitution. At least one researcher has found that there are some early versions of the Constitution floating around that had this phantom nobility amendment printed in it for a few decades. Now, as recently as 2020, the National Archives acknowledged that it could still become part of the Constitution. But because so many states have joined since 1814, we'd need 38 states for ratification. So it doesn't count that it got the necessary three-fourths, like back when it went. Well, interestingly enough, there's like this entire conspiracy theory online where actually people claim that it was secretly, you know, de facto part of the Constitution because we got the right number at the time.
And so that it's in operation and we need to be careful about it. Wow. Yeah. That's super interesting. So weird. More on Article 1 when we come back. One of the things I also sort of notice in the section 9 of what Congress can't do is there's lots of sort of vague, circumspect language about basically not outlawing slavery for the next 30 years is a huge part of what's in there. Could you talk a little bit about that?
Sure. I mean, I think, you know, we've talked before a bit about like the lingering part of the shadow of slavery in this document, which is a lot. and regulates our national government today. But these, of course, are very specific compromises in the Constitution, responding to concerns that how do you get all of the states to join on to this brand-new experimental constitution, right? That was meant to respond to the failures of the Articles of Confederation. So it's kind of like this ugly stain that remains part of the original document,
just floating out there, of course, overridden by later parts of the Constitution, the reconstruction amendments. but it's kind of these, it's like a shadow, of course, something that we can't ignore and certainly is part of the history. So that's the strange thing about the Constitution. It's built, it's like a ramshackle building built with things that absolutely don't make any sense anymore and things that vitally regulate everything we do today. You know, we can't jettison those parts. We'd have to sort of create a new constitution from scratch. But I think, you know, as our earlier guest, Nicole Hannah-Jones had mentioned, that you can't ignore it either. That's part of our history.
It's just sort of interesting in its language just sort of like to go, like, okay, so there's a lot of impulse to ban slavery outright, but they never want to invoke the word slavery. But there's all these like provisions like, well, they can't sort of tax it out of existence. They can't stop sort of certain types of international, you know, like immigration is like there's like lots of different language to sort of work around the idea of saying basically like if you, the state of South Carolina, sign on to this, we won't ban slavery for the next 30 years. years for you to figure out how you're going to like function as an economy without slavery. It's just sort of, it's fascinating, you know, like it's all built in there. And in fact that, you know, like that it's still in there, there's like a general thing that's kind of interesting that's not, you know, not necessarily intuitive on the face of it is that we keep everything in the Constitution.
You could rewrite it like and just like jettison all these parts. But we chose to keep everything permanent and everything. that's changed we add amendments to but there's nothing you know like we're at the very beginning of exploring what a written constitution is and they could have they could have decided that no we actually like revise and replace these parts but we chose not to we could but i suppose there's also like a different argument to say there's some merit in keeping even that ugly history in there to remind us that just to remind us that you know this was part of the founding and we don't want to whitewash what happened then or what the assumptions or ideas were even of the founding fathers,
even if they had these kind of timeless ideas about due process and liberty and the availability of habeas corpus, they also had some ideas that we consider profoundly objectionable today. And it's important to just keep it there so that we can learn something about history. It is a historical document as well as a governing document. Yeah, I totally agree. I just think that's sort of, it's interesting to think through that they were doing all of this for the first time. And you could totally say, like, you know what, we just want to revise the Constitution. I mean, like, Jefferson, you know, thought that you should revise the Constitution every 19 years and
even if they had these kind of timeless ideas about due process and liberty and the availability of habeas corpus, they also had some ideas that we consider profoundly objectionable today. And it's important to just keep it there so that we can learn something about history. It is a historical document as well as a governing document. Yeah, I totally agree. I just think that's sort of, it's interesting to think through that they were doing all of this for the first time. And you could totally say, like, you know what, we just want to revise the Constitution. I mean, like, Jefferson, you know, thought that you should revise the Constitution every 19 years and|||尽管他们有关于正当程序、自由和人身保护令适用性的这种永恒理念，但他们也有一些我们今天认为极其令人反感的想法。把这些保留下来很重要，这样我们就能从中了解历史。它既是一份历史文件，也是一份治理文件。是的，我完全同意。我只是觉得，回想他们当时是在第一次做这一切，这种思考过程很有趣。你完全可以说，比如，你知道吗，我们就是想修改宪法。我的意思是，比如杰斐逊，你知道的，他认为你应该每19年修改一次宪法，
basically rewrite it, just, like, form another constitutional convention and say, like, what are the rules that should govern us now? And instead, we keep this legacy of everything that was written before. And that was also a design choice. I just want people to sort of, like, think about that. They didn't have to do it this way. And I think it's interesting that they decided to just, like, build and build and build and, you know, keep everything that came before it. And so when you read these sections, you're like, what are they talking about? Like, you really have to like look through and just like, oh, they're talking about slavery here. They're talking about keeping slavery legal for 30 years, no matter what, you know, Congress wants to do or the will of Congress wants
basically rewrite it, just, like, form another constitutional convention and say, like, what are the rules that should govern us now? And instead, we keep this legacy of everything that was written before. And that was also a design choice. I just want people to sort of, like, think about that. They didn't have to do it this way. And I think it's interesting that they decided to just, like, build and build and build and, you know, keep everything that came before it. And so when you read these sections, you're like, what are the talks about? Like, you really have to like look through and just like, oh, they're talking about slavery here. They're talking about keeping slavery legal for 30 years, no matter what, you know, Congress wants to do or the will of Congress wants|||基本上重写它，就像是，组建另一个制宪会议，然后说，现在应该用什么规则来统治我们？相反，我们保留了以前写的一切的遗产。这也是一种设计选择。我只是想让大家思考一下这一点。他们其实不必非得这么做。而且我觉得很有趣的是，他们决定不断地建设、建设、再建设，你知道的，保留之前的一切。所以当你阅读这些章节时，你会想，他们在谈论什么？比如，你真的必须仔细浏览然后发现，哦，他们这里在谈论奴隶制。他们谈论的是无论如何都要让奴隶制合法化30年，不管你知道的，国会想做什么，或者国会的意愿想要
to do just so we can get southern states on board. And I think it's interesting. Yeah. And in a way, it's kind of funny because the constitution itself, I mean, the project of the convention was to revise the Articles of Confederation. So they actually didn't even do what they were supposed to do, right? So they were like, forget that project. We'll just create a new one from scratch. Yeah, that in and of itself.
to do just so we can get southern states on board. And I think it's interesting. Yeah. And in a way, it's kind of funny because the constitution itself, I mean, the project of the convention was to revise the Articles of Confederation. So they actually didn't even do what they were supposed to do, right? So they were like, forget that project. We'll just create a new one from scratch. Yeah, that in and of itself.|||这样做只是为了让南方各州加入进来。我觉得这很有意思。是的。从某种程度上说，这有点搞笑，因为宪法本身——我的意思是，这次会议的计划本来是修改《邦联条例》。所以他们实际上甚至没有做他们本该做的事，对吧？所以他们当时的想法是，忘掉那个计划吧。我们直接从头创建一个新的。是的，这件事本身就是如此。
I mean, that was kind of more of the precedent, was just a restart. And but we just said that this was now the starting point and now all changes would happen, you know, like as an additive to this thing that was created. Right. And that's just kind of fascinating. It just didn't have to be that way.
I mean, that was kind of more of the precedent, was just a restart. And but we just said that this was now the starting point and now all changes would happen, you know, like as an additive to this thing that was created. Right. And that's just kind of fascinating. It just didn't have to be that way.|||我的意思是，那更像是一个先例，就是一个重新开始。但是我们只是说，这现在成了起点，从现在开始所有的改变都会发生，你知道的，就像是对这个被创造出来的事物的一种叠加。没错。这简直太迷人了。事情本来不一定非得是这样的。
In fact, clearly is evidence by the transition from the Articles' Confederation to the U.S. Constitution. They didn't, you know, they didn't think it needed to happen that way at that moment. Right. So, okay, so those are some things that Congress can't do. Okay. So let's turn to Section 10. Okay. All right. So Section 10 is quite different. It contains a long list of things that the states cannot do. So why are there limitations on what states can do in Article 1, since this is like, what, you know, this was still outlined what Congress can do? Okay, well, part of the reason is that some of the prohibitions on the states can be lifted if Congress consents.
In fact, clearly is evidence by the transition from the Articles' Confederation to the U.S. Constitution. They didn't, you know, they didn't think it needed to happen that way at that moment. Right. So, okay, so those are some things that Congress can't do. Okay. So let's turn to Section 10. Okay. All right. So Section 10 is quite different. It contains a long list of things that the states cannot do. So why are there limitations on what states can do in Article 1, since this is like, what, you know, this was still outlined what Congress can do? Okay, well, part of the reason is that some of the prohibitions on the states can be lifted if Congress consents.|||事实上，从《邦联条例》到美国宪法的过渡就是明显的证明。他们当时并不认为，你知道的，事情必须以那种方式发生。没错。好了，这些是国会不能做的一些事情。好，那我们转向第10条。好。行吧，第10条很不一样。它包含了一长串各州不能做的事情。那么，既然第一条是在概述国会能做什么，为什么其中还会限制各州能做什么呢？好吧，部分原因在于，如果国会同意，对各州的一些禁令是可以解除的。
So clause two says that states are not allowed to impose any imposts or duties on exports or imports unless Congress agrees. So this is a provision that limits the ability of the states to interfere with interstate commerce. But if for whatever crazy reason, Congress wants to let them do that, they can do that, right? clause three of section 10 says that the states can't keep troops or ships of war in a time of peace or even enter into compacts with other states unless again congress consents so the first part of that is a reminder that war and diplomacy are supposed to be the responsibility of the federal government not the states but states can enter into compacts if congress lets them and over time there have been many interstate compacts where states agree to get together to solve regional problems.
So clause two says that states are not allowed to impose any imposts or duties on exports or imports unless Congress agrees. So this is a provision that limits the ability of the states to interfere with interstate commerce. But if for whatever crazy reason, Congress wants to let them do that, they can do that, right? clause three of section 10 says that the states can't keep troops or ships of war in a time of peace or even enter into compacts with other states unless again congress consents so the first part of that is a reminder that war and diplomacy are supposed to be the responsibility of the federal government not the states but states can enter into compacts if congress lets them and over time there have been many interstate compacts where states agree to get together to solve regional problems.|||因此，第二款规定，除非国会同意，否则不允许各州对进出口征收任何苛捐杂税或关税。因此，这是一项限制各州干涉州际贸易能力的条款。但是，如果出于某种疯狂的原因，国会想要让他们这样做，他们就可以这样做，对吧？第10条第三款规定，在和平时期，各州不得保留军队或军舰，甚至不得与其他州缔结契约，除非国会再次同意。因此，这第一部分是在提醒人们，战争和外交本应是联邦政府的责任，而不是各州的责任，但如果国会允许，各州可以缔结契约。随着时间的推移，出现了许多州际契约，各州通过这些契约同意联合起来解决地区问题。
And these interstate agreements span everything from regulating water, fisheries, oil and gas, urban planning, even sewage disposal. And the Supreme Court has interpreted this compact clause so that Congress actually isn't required to approve every single thing that might be considered an agreement among the states, just like the really important ones. And so the basic idea is that Congress should be required to approve of an interstate compact.
And these interstate agreements span everything from regulating water, fisheries, oil and gas, urban planning, even sewage disposal. And the Supreme Court has interpreted this compact clause so that Congress actually isn't required to approve every single thing that might be considered an agreement among the states, just like the really important ones. And so the basic idea is that Congress should be required to approve of an interstate compact.|||这些州际协议涵盖了从水资源、渔业、石油和天然气、城市规划到污水处理等方方面面。最高法院对这一契约条款进行了诠释，使得国会实际上无需批准可能被视为州际协议的每一件小事，而只需批准那些真正重要的事情。因此，其基本理念是，国会理应被要求批准州际契约。
if it somehow challenges or affects the supremacy of the federal government, right? Now, I bring this up because I think because of the times we're living in now, I wouldn't be surprised if we start to see more and more interstate compacts, particularly on the coasts of states that are getting together to try and solve problems because they think the federal government isn't sharing their values or because the institutions of the federal government have degraded or collapsed altogether. Mm-hmm. And so would each of these compacts then have to be, like, adjudicated by the Supreme Court or what would happen here? Or approved by Congress? You know, like... So, yeah, so it depends.
if it somehow challenges or affects the supremacy of the federal government, right? Now, I bring this up because I think because of the times we're living in now, I wouldn't be surprised if we start to see more and more interstate compacts, particularly on the coasts of states that are getting together to try and solve problems because they think the federal government isn't sharing their values or because the institutions of the federal government have degraded or collapsed altogether. Mm-hmm. And so would each of these compacts then have to be, like, adjudicated by the Supreme Court or what would happen here? Or approved by Congress? You know, like... So, yeah, so it depends.|||如果它在某种程度上挑战或影响了联邦政府的至高无上地位的话，对吧？现在，我提出这一点是因为我认为，鉴于我们目前所处的时代，如果我们开始看到越来越多的州际契约，我一点也不会感到惊讶，特别是那些沿海各州联合起来试图解决问题，因为他们认为联邦政府与他们没有共同的价值观，或者因为联邦政府的机构已经退化或彻底崩溃。嗯哼。那么，这些契约中的每一个都需要像是由最高法院裁决，还是会发生什么情况？或者需要国会批准？你知道的，比如……所以，是的，这要看情况。
So, as I said, the Supreme Court doesn't consider every kind of agreement among a group of states to be a compact for purposes of the compact clause. So they have to have certain features. And also, if it's of a type that might challenge what the federal government has primary responsibility over, then it might be a problematic compact unless Congress says, yes, you can go ahead and do that. Wow. So some of these compacts, like regulating, you know, let's say like a nuclear waste, that in the past has been something that Congress has approved of. But there are lots of other things where states have gone together and, you know, they just do it because they don't rise to the level of super importance so that, you know, Congress definitely has to come in and act. But I just mean in terms of values and the kind of conflicts that we're seeing now, it wouldn't surprise me again if we see more and more of these states getting together and saying we want to do something different. And there's people lobbying for this, like this sort of soft, soft secession style of, of, like, forming our own values amongst the sort of the Pacific states and stuff like this.
So, as I said, the Supreme Court doesn't consider every kind of agreement among a group of states to be a compact for purposes of the compact clause. So they have to have certain features. And also, if it's of a type that might challenge what the federal government has primary responsibility over, then it might be a problematic compact unless Congress says, yes, you can go ahead and do that. Wow. So some of these compacts, like regulating, you know, let's say like a nuclear waste, that in the past has been something that Congress has approved of. But there are lots of other things where states have gone together and, you know, they just do it because they don't rise to the level of super importance so that, you know, Congress definitely has to come in and act. But I just mean in terms of values and the kind of conflicts that we're seeing now, it wouldn't surprise me again if we see more and more of these states getting together and saying we want to do something different. And there's people lobbying for this, like this sort of soft, soft secession style of, of, like, forming our own values amongst the sort of the Pacific states and stuff like this.|||所以，正如我所说，最高法院并不认为一群州之间的每一种协议都属于契约条款所指的契约。因此，它们必须具备某些特征。此外，如果某种类型的协议可能会挑战联邦政府拥有主要管辖权的事项，那么它可能就是一个有问题的契约，除非国会说，可以，你们可以继续这样做。哇。所以其中一些契约，比如监管，你知道的，比方说核废料，过去这是国会批准过的事情。但还有很多其他事情是各州联合起来去做的，你知道的，他们这样做只是因为这些事情还没上升到超级重要的程度，以至于国会必须介入并采取行动。但我的意思是，就价值观以及我们现在看到的各种冲突而言，如果我们再次看到越来越多的这些州联合起来说我们想做点不一样的，我一点也不会感到惊讶。而且有人正在为此进行游说，比如这种软分裂风格的，在太平洋沿岸各州等地区之间形成我们自己的价值观。
And you can imagine ones that would immediately get knocked down, like, if a collection of states decided to have their own gun laws, that would probably get, like, immediately, like, knocked down. Yeah, probably, I think so. But other ones that seem more possible? Well, I mean, there are things that are happening right now that. it's not clear what the details are, but you've heard of these compacts or agreements by the Western states and the northeastern states about health alliances, right? Yeah.
And you can imagine ones that would immediately get knocked down, like, if a collection of states decided to have their own gun laws, that would probably get, like, immediately, like, knocked down. Yeah, probably, I think so. But other ones that seem more possible? Well, I mean, there are things that are happening right now that. it's not clear what the details are, but you've heard of these compacts or agreements by the Western states and the northeastern states about health alliances, right? Yeah.|||你可以想象那些会立即被否决的契约，比如，如果一群州决定制定自己的枪支法，那可能会立即被否决。是的，可能吧，我也这么认为。但其他看起来更有可能的呢？嗯，我是说，现在正在发生一些事情，细节虽然还不清楚，但你听说过西部各州和东北部各州关于健康联盟的这些契约或协议吗？是的。
Like trying to recommend, well, this is what we think that our citizens should get in terms of vaccine schedules, even though our Secretary of Health and Human Services says vaccines are bad and you don't need them. So that might be something that, in theory, is contemplated by the clause, but, you know, depending on how they do the arrangement and whether it truly is a compact
Like trying to recommend, well, this is what we think that our citizens should get in terms of vaccine schedules, even though our Secretary of Health and Human Services says vaccines are bad and you don't need them. So that might be something that, in theory, is contemplated by the clause, but, you know, depending on how they do the arrangement and whether it truly is a compact|||比如试图推荐：嗯，这就是我们认为我们的公民在疫苗接种时间表方面应该得到的，尽管我们的卫生与公众服务部长说疫苗不好，你们不需要它们。所以这可能是一项在理论上属于该条款设想范围的事情，但是，你知道的，这取决于他们如何进行安排，以及它是否真正是一个契约
and whether it's the type of compact that would be regulated by the compact clause, we'll have to see. Okay. And the first clause of Section 10 involves matters which cannot be waived by Congress. It flat out tells states things that they just cannot do.
and whether it's the type of compact that would be regulated by the compact clause, we'll have to see. Okay. And the first clause of Section 10 involves matters which cannot be waived by Congress. It flat out tells states things that they just cannot do.|||并且它是否属于受契约条款管制的契约类型，我们拭目以待。好的。第10条的第一款涉及国会不能豁免的事项。它直截了当地告诉各州有些事是绝对不能做的。
The states are not allowed to coin money. That's left for the federal government. And the Constitution bans the states from passing bills of attainder or ex post facto laws. in the same way that Congress is not allowed to do. So these are laws that single out a person or entity for punishment or laws that retroactively make conduct illegal.
The states are not allowed to coin money. That's left for the federal government. And the Constitution bans the states from passing bills of attainder or ex post facto laws. in the same way that Congress is not allowed to do. So these are laws that single out a person or entity for punishment or laws that retroactively make conduct illegal.|||各州不允许自己铸造货币。这留给联邦政府去做。宪法禁止各州通过剥夺公民权利法案（bills of attainder）或事后溯及法（ex post facto laws），就像国会不允许这样做一样。这些法律是指针对某个人或实体进行惩罚的法律，或者是使某种行为具有追溯性违 宪/违法的法律。
And interestingly enough, the same section says that no state shall enter into any confederation. And that is the reason why the Confederacy itself is inconsistent with the Constitution. Interesting. Okay. How about an Article I power that may not seem terribly relevant today, but still pretty cool to know about. Okay, let's hear it. Okay. So if you look at Congress's war power in Section 8, it says Congress shall have the power to declare war and grant letters of mark and reprisal.
And interestingly enough, the same section says that no state shall enter into any confederation. And that is the reason why the Confederacy itself is inconsistent with the Constitution. Interesting. Okay. How about an Article I power that may not seem terribly relevant today, but still pretty cool to know about. Okay, let's hear it. Okay. So if you look at Congress's war power in Section 8, it says Congress shall have the power to declare war and grant letters of mark and reprisal.|||更有趣的是，同一条款规定，任何州都不得加入任何邦联。这就是为什么南部邦联本身与宪法不符的原因。很有意思。好的。那我们来看看第一条中的一项权力，它在今天可能看起来不怎么相关，但了解一下还是很酷的。好吧，说来听听。好的。如果你看看第八条中国会的战争权力，它规定国会有权宣战并颁发私掠许可证（letters of marque and reprisal）。
Okay. What does that mean? Okay. A letter of mark and reprisal is a document, an official authorization by the government that allows a private citizen to seize an enemy ship, including their cargo and crew. So letters of mark and reprisal have been around. since the middle ages. And if you were granted such a letter, you were known as a privateer. A privateer, because you were using your privately owned ship to engage with the enemy so you could reap a financial reward. That's like master and commander kind of stuff.
Okay. What does that mean? Okay. A letter of mark and reprisal is a document, an official authorization by the government that allows a private citizen to seize an enemy ship, including their cargo and crew. So letters of mark and reprisal have been around. since the middle ages. And if you were granted such a letter, you were known as a privateer. A privateer, because you were using your privately owned ship to engage with the enemy so you could reap a financial reward. That's like master and commander kind of stuff.|||好吧。这是什么意思？好的。私掠许可证（letters of marque and reprisal）是一份文件，是政府的官方授权，允许私营公民扣押敌方船只，包括其货物和船员。因此，私掠许可证自中世纪以来就存在了。如果你被授予这样一封信，你就会被称为私掠船员（privateer）。私掠船员，因为你使用的是自己私有的船只与敌人交战，以便从中获得经济回报。这有点像电影《怒海争锋：极地征伐》里的那种桥段。
Yeah, sure, sure. So like you're not a pirate, you're doing something legally because the government's allowing you to do it. So letters of mark and reprisal are extremely useful if you don't have a large naval fleet. So that was the case during the Revolutionary War. So, Massachusetts, for instance, began issuing letters of mark and reprisal in 1775, and the second Continental Congress distributed these letters to the colonies so that privateers could capture British ships. We just didn't have a large naval presence. And in the first few decades after the Constitution was adopted, Congress issued letters of mark and reprisal. And the Civil War was the last significant use of these letters. The Confederacy used privateers. Lincoln had the authority
Yeah, sure, sure. So like you're not a pirate, you're doing something legally because the government's allowing you to do it. So letters of mark and reprisal are extremely useful if you don't have a large naval fleet. So that was the case during the Revolutionary War. So, Massachusetts, for instance, began issuing letters of mark and reprisal in 1775, and the second Continental Congress distributed these letters to the colonies so that privateers could capture British ships. We just didn't have a large naval presence. And in the first few decades after the Constitution was adopted, Congress issued letters of mark and reprisal. And the Civil War was the last significant use of these letters. The Confederacy used privateers. Lincoln had the authority|||是的，当然，当然。所以你不是海盗，你做的是合法的事情，因为政府允许你这样做。因此，如果你没有庞大的海军舰队，私掠许可证就极其有用。独立战争期间就是这种情况。例如，马萨诸塞州在1775年开始颁发私掠许可证，第二届大陆会议将这些许可证分发给各殖民地，以便私掠船员能够捕获英国船只。我们当时就是没有庞大的海军力量。在宪法通过后的最初几十年里，国会一直在颁发私掠许可证。内战是对这些许可证的最后一次重大使用。南部邦联使用过私掠船员。林肯有权力
to use privateers, but he, in fact, didn't. Okay. So I did say letters of mark and reprisal weren't all that relevant to our daily lives, but I should mention there have been some attempts to revive the idea. Oh, yeah. This doesn't sound good, so. Right, doesn't. So in February of this year, 2025, Senator Mike Lee of Utah suggested that, well,
to use privateers, but he, in fact, didn't. Okay. So I did say letters of mark and reprisal weren't all that relevant to our daily lives, but I should mention there have been some attempts to revive the idea. Oh, yeah. This doesn't sound good, so. Right, doesn't. So in February of this year, 2025, Senator Mike Lee of Utah suggested that, well,|||使用私掠船员，但他事实上并没有这么做。好的。所以我确实说过，私掠许可证与我们的日常生活关联不大，但我应该提一下，曾有人试图复兴这个想法。哦，是的。这听起来可不太妙。确实不太妙。因此，在今年（2025年）2月，犹他州参议员迈克·李（Mike Lee）建议说，嗯，
maybe Congress should allow privateers to take on illegal drug cartels at the Mexican border. Wow. And he specifically mentioned Congress's ability to issue letters of mark and reprisal in Article 1, Section 8. Wow. And so this was sort of de facto deputized private citizens to go after drug cartels. And in payment, they would actually take whatever they took down or stole. Well, that's the part that's nonsensical. What do you think to take? But do you take the drugs?
maybe Congress should allow privateers to take on illegal drug cartels at the Mexican border. Wow. And he specifically mentioned Congress's ability to issue letters of mark and reprisal in Article 1, Section 8. Wow. And so this was sort of de facto deputized private citizens to go after drug cartels. And in payment, they would actually take whatever they took down or stole. Well, that's the part that's nonsensical. What do you think to take? But do you take the drugs?|||或许国会应该允许私掠船员在墨西哥边境对付非法的贩毒集团。哇。他特别提到了国会在第一条第八款中颁发私掠许可证的能力。哇。所以这实际上是变相授权普通公民去追捕贩毒集团。作为报酬，他们实际上会拿走他们击落或掠夺的一切东西。嗯，这正是荒谬的部分。你觉得他们会拿什么？难道去拿毒品吗？
Yeah, that doesn't make any sense of all. You would sell the drugs? Yeah. He didn't think that part out. But, yes, in theory, that's how it would work. Oh, my gosh. That is not a good world to live in. Right.
Yeah, that doesn't make any sense of all. You would sell the drugs? Yeah. He didn't think that part out. But, yes, in theory, that's how it would work. Oh, my gosh. That is not a good world to live in. Right.|||是的，这根本说不通。你要去卖毒品吗？对。他没有把那部分想清楚。但是，是的，从理论上讲，事情就是这样运作的。我的天呐。那可不是一个适合生存的好世界。没错。
But it's still there, and it's an authority of Congress. Okay. Okay. All right. So lastly, let's talk about a power that I think a lot of folks might think is an Article 1, but isn't there at all. If they think about Article 1 at all, yeah. Right, if they think about Article 1. But, yeah, go ahead.
But it's still there, and it's an authority of Congress. Okay. Okay. All right. So lastly, let's talk about a power that I think a lot of folks might think is an Article 1, but isn't there at all. If they think about Article 1 at all, yeah. Right, if they think about Article 1. But, yeah, go ahead.|||但它仍然存在，而且这是国会的一项权力。好的。好的。行吧，最后，我们来谈谈一项权力，我想很多人可能会认为它在第一条里，但实际上根本不在那里。如果他们去想第一条的话，是的。没错，如果他们考虑第一条的话。但是，好吧，请继续。
So, Roman, you know that Trump's second term has focused on his mass deportation agenda. Yeah. And the rules about who is considered unlawfully within the United States. Who may stay, and for what reasons, these are all determined by Congress. But if you think about it, why can Congress do this? So it's a serious question because although Article 1 has a commerce power, a taxing and spending power, and even has a clause that provides the authority to establish post offices, there is no immigration clause. Yeah, I guess I hadn't really thought about that, but yeah.
So, Roman, you know that Trump's second term has focused on his mass deportation agenda. Yeah. And the rules about who is considered unlawfully within the United States. Who may stay, and for what reasons, these are all determined by Congress. But if you think about it, why can Congress do this? So it's a serious question because although Article 1 has a commerce power, a taxing and spending power, and even has a clause that provides the authority to establish post offices, there is no immigration clause. Yeah, I guess I hadn't really thought about that, but yeah.|||所以，罗曼，你知道特朗普的第二任期一直专注于他的大规模驱逐计划。是的。关于谁被视为非法身处美国境内的规则。谁可以留下，出于什么原因，这些都是由国会决定的。但如果你仔细想想，为什么国会能做到这一点？这是一个严肃的问题，因为尽管第一条拥有商业权力、征税和支出的权力，甚至还有一项授权建立邮局的条款，但却没有移民条款。是的，我想我以前真的没怎么想过这个问题，但是是的。
The Constitution doesn't mention the word immigration at all. The Constitution doesn't give any branch of the federal government the ability to control how non-citizens can come to the United States, how they can stay, or whether they can live here. Now, Article 1, Section 8 does give Congress the power to regulate naturalization. That's the process of how a non-citizen can become a citizen. But that's not nearly enough of a basis to allow Congress to regulate everything there is, regarding immigration. Okay. So what is that built on then?
The Constitution doesn't mention the word immigration at all. The Constitution doesn't give any branch of the federal government the ability to control how non-citizens can come to the United States, how they can stay, or whether they can live here. Now, Article 1, Section 8 does give Congress the power to regulate naturalization. That's the process of how a non-citizen can become a citizen. But that's not nearly enough of a basis to allow Congress to regulate everything there is, regarding immigration. Okay. So what is that built on then?|||宪法根本没有提到“移民”这个词。宪法没有赋予联邦政府任何部门控制非公民如何来到美国、如何停留或是否可以在这里居住的能力。现在，第一条第八款确实赋予了国会规范归化入籍（naturalization）的权力。这是非公民如何成为公民的过程。但这远不足以构成让国会监管与移民相关的一切事物的依据。好的。那这建立在什么基础之上呢？
Well, for a long time now, the Supreme Court has said the ability to regulate immigration just comes from the United States being a country, from being a sovereign nation. And since every sovereign nation can regulate its borders, that means that the United States has the immigration authority. So according to the Supreme Court, that inherent power, not men's. mentioned in the Constitution at all, is plenary or full, and it belongs to Congress. And that also means that the President of the United States has broad authority to enforce these laws. So that's a kind of surprising observation, I think, for a lot of people.
Well, for a long time now, the Supreme Court has said the ability to regulate immigration just comes from the United States being a country, from being a sovereign nation. And since every sovereign nation can regulate its borders, that means that the United States has the immigration authority. So according to the Supreme Court, that inherent power, not men's. mentioned in the Constitution at all, is plenary or full, and it belongs to Congress. And that also means that the President of the United States has broad authority to enforce these laws. So that's a kind of surprising observation, I think, for a lot of people.|||嗯，很长一段时间以来，最高法院一直表示，监管移民的能力仅仅来自于美国是一个国家，来自于作为一个主权国家。既然每个主权国家都可以管理其边境，这就意味着美国拥有移民管辖权。因此，根据最高法院的说法，这种宪法中完全没有提及的固有权力是全权的或完整的，属于国会。这也意味着美国总统拥有广泛的权力来执行这些法律。因此，我认为对于很多人来说，这是一个有点令人惊奇的观察。
This enormous amount of national power, the one that is being used by President Trump for his mass deportation agenda, isn't mentioned in the Constitution at all. Wow. That's definitely something to think about. I mean, oh, my God. But that could also break both ways, right? Like, it could give all kinds of power that are not written down, or you could interpret it as you have no power to do anything.
This enormous amount of national power, the one that is being used by President Trump for his mass deportation agenda, isn't mentioned in the Constitution at all. Wow. That's definitely something to think about. I mean, oh, my God. But that could also break both ways, right? Like, it could give all kinds of power that are not written down, or you could interpret it as you have no power to do anything.|||这种巨大的国家权力——正是特朗普总统用来推行其大规模驱逐计划的权力——在宪法中根本没有被提及。哇。这绝对是值得深思的事情。我的意思是，天哪。但这也有可能是双刃剑，对吧？比如，它可能会赋予各种未写下来的权力，或者你也可以将其解释为你们无权做任何事情。
Yeah, I mean, historical practice suggests that we've always assumed that there is immigration power. I mean, even the founders thought there was an immigration power. What's kind of surprising is that we didn't bother to mention it in the document. Yeah. And so it becomes a question as to, how can you even start to talk about the outer boundaries of that power if we don't even have any words to start with? And mostly they've just sort of treated as this is just so standard that we build it on sort of a common sense understanding of what a country is and that's it. Yeah. I mean, for sure the Supreme Court has at times referred to some parts of the Constitution like, you know, we have the ability to regulate foreign commerce.
Yeah, I mean, historical practice suggests that we've always assumed that there is immigration power. I mean, even the founders thought there was an immigration power. What's kind of surprising is that we didn't bother to mention it in the document. Yeah. And so it becomes a question as to, how can you even start to talk about the outer boundaries of that power if we don't even have any words to start with? And mostly they've just sort of treated as this is just so standard that we build it on sort of a common sense understanding of what a country is and that's it. Yeah. I mean, for sure the Supreme Court has at times referred to some parts of the Constitution like, you know, we have the ability to regulate foreign commerce.|||是的，我是说，历史实践表明，我们一直假设存在移民权力。我的意思是，甚至连建国先父们也认为存在移民权力。有点令人惊讶的是，我们竟然懒得在文件中提及它。是的。因此这就成了一个问题：如果我们连起码的字句都没有，又怎么能开始谈论这种权力的外部边界呢？而且他们大多只是把它当作是如此标准的东西，以至于我们把它建立在对国家是什么的常识性理解之上，仅此而已。是的。我的意思是，可以肯定的是，最高法院有时会引用宪法的某些部分，比如，你知道的，我们有能力规范对外贸易。
the president has a foreign affairs power. And again, there's this congressional ability to regulate naturalization. So I guess if you put them together and sprinkle something on it, that would turn into the immigration power. But yeah, mainly the idea is because the United States is a sovereign nation
the president has a foreign affairs power. And again, there's this congressional ability to regulate naturalization. So I guess if you put them together and sprinkle something on it, that would turn into the immigration power. But yeah, mainly the idea is because the United States is a sovereign nation|||总统拥有外交事务权力。还有国会规范归化入籍的能力。所以我想，如果你把它们放在一起并加上点什么，那就会变成移民权力。但是，是的，主要的观点是因为美国是一个主权国家
like any other, it has to have the ability to regulate immigration. But again, that's a, you know, in a rule of law context, it would be better if we had something more sturdy to rest that on. Yeah, yeah. I mean, would it be worth to you to, like, put something in some kind of an amendment that made sense here?
like any other, it has to have the ability to regulate immigration. But again, that's a, you know, in a rule of law context, it would be better if we had something more sturdy to rest that on. Yeah, yeah. I mean, would it be worth to you to, like, put something in some kind of an amendment that made sense here?|||和其他国家一样，它必须具备监管移民的能力。但话又说回来，你知道的，在法治的语境下，如果我们能有一些更坚实的东西作为支撑，那就更好了。对，对。我的意思是，你会觉得值得把某些说得通的东西写进某种修正案里吗？
Or is it like at this point you couldn't really codify it into language? Well, I mean, I think it would be useful, you know, in an imaginary world we could easily do this to put it into language that, you know, it is Congress that has the immigration authority. And that may be putting some limits on how the executive branch can enforce the immigration power or it's specifying. what the executive branch is allowed to do. Because at the moment, we seem to have a Congress that is totally acquiescing to the president's assertions about immigration authority and saying that, in fact, I can do whatever I want because Article 2 gives me complete authority to do whatever. And again, that's hard to come back with saying, but the text says this because the text doesn't say anything. Because there is no defense. Right.
Or is it like at this point you couldn't really codify it into language? Well, I mean, I think it would be useful, you know, in an imaginary world we could easily do this to put it into language that, you know, it is Congress that has the immigration authority. And that may be putting some limits on how the executive branch can enforce the immigration power or it's specifying. what the executive branch is allowed to do. Because at the moment, we seem to have a Congress that is totally acquiescing to the president's assertions about immigration authority and saying that, in fact, I can do whatever I want because Article 2 gives me complete authority to do whatever. And again, that's hard to come back with saying, but the text says this because the text doesn't say anything. Because there is no defense. Right.|||还是说到了这一步，你其实根本无法把它编纂成文字？嗯，我的意思是，我认为这会很有用，你知道，在一个想象的世界里，我们可以轻松地做到这一点，把它写成文字，即，你知道的，拥有移民管辖权的是国会。这可能会对行政部门如何执行移民权力施加一些限制，或者明确规定行政部门被允许做什么。因为目前，我们的国会似乎完全默许了总统关于移民权力的主张，并声称，事实上，我想做什么就能做什么，因为第二条赋予了我做任何事情的完整权力。再说一次，很难用“但是文本上是这么说的”来进行反驳，因为文本上根本什么都没说。因为根本没有防守的余地。没错。
Because there's nothing there. Right. There's no there. Wow. That's so fascinating. Okay. Well, this is what is coming to me in this moment where we're talking. And, you know, like, even the sentence that we mentioned earlier, this, like, the privilege of the writ of habeas corpus shall not be suspended unless in cases of rebellion and invasion, the public safety may require it.
Because there's nothing there. Right. There's no there. Wow. That's so fascinating. Okay. Well, this is what is coming to me in this moment where we're talking. And, you know, like, even the sentence that we mentioned earlier, this, like, the privilege of the writ of habeas corpus shall not be suspended unless in cases of rebellion and invasion, the public safety may require it.|||因为那里什么都没有。没错。那儿空无一物。哇。太迷人了。好的。嗯，这就是我们在交谈的这一刻涌上我心头的事情。而且，你知道，就像我们之前提到的那句话，比如，“人身保护令（writ of habeas corpus）的特权不得中止，除非在叛乱或入侵的情况下，公共安全的需要”。
Like, there's lots of things in here that allow for evildoing. Like, the Constitution is not a backstop against evil doing. Like, it allows for quite a bit of mischief and making. people's lives miserable, that you can't really depend on the Constitution for that. You have to really depend on, you know, the ethics and goodness of humans, really. I think that's right. And, I mean, in fact, if you look at the Constitution, you know, a lot of it seems to explicitly contemplate, look, if there's an emergency, we can suspend some of these rules. But, you know, who gets to declare the emergency and what exactly is an emergency? That's a matter of political
Like, there's lots of things in here that allow for evildoing. Like, the Constitution is not a backstop against evil doing. Like, it allows for quite a bit of mischief and making. people's lives miserable, that you can't really depend on the Constitution for that. You have to really depend on, you know, the ethics and goodness of humans, really. I think that's right. And, I mean, in fact, if you look at the Constitution, you know, a lot of it seems to explicitly contemplate, look, if there's an emergency, we can suspend some of these rules. But, you know, who gets to declare the emergency and what exactly is an emergency? That's a matter of political|||这里面有很多允许作恶的事情。比如，宪法并不是防止作恶的最后防线。比如，它允许相当多的恶作剧和让人们的生活陷入水深火热之中的行为，你真的不能指望宪法来阻止这些。你真的必须依靠，你知道的，人类的道德和善良，真的。我认为是这样的。而且，我的意思是，事实上，如果你看一下宪法，你知道的，其中很大一部分似乎明确设想了：看，如果有紧急情况，我们可以暂停其中一些规则。但是，你知道，谁来宣布紧急状态，究竟什么是紧急状态？这是一个政治问题
accountability. It's not something that the Constitution sets limits on. Yeah. Yeah. This idea of emergency. They're like these sort of pull the court in case of emergency stuff that it's kind of everywhere in the Constitution. They were nervous about making something that tied Congress's hands like a little too much. Yeah. And of course, you know, the contemplated emergencies were being invaded, which was like a serious threat and concern at the time of the founding. I think, you know, they wouldn't have contemplated a president that would have used immigration as an emergency. to say, well, that's why we can detain people without charge or access to the courts.
accountability. It's not something that the Constitution sets limits on. Yeah. Yeah. This idea of emergency. They're like these sort of pull the court in case of emergency stuff that it's kind of everywhere in the Constitution. They were nervous about making something that tied Congress's hands like a little too much. Yeah. And of course, you know, the contemplated emergencies were being invaded, which was like a serious threat and concern at the time of the founding. I think, you know, they wouldn't have contemplated a president that would have used immigration as an emergency. to say, well, that's why we can detain people without charge or access to the courts.|||问责制。这不是宪法设定限制的事情。是的。是的。这种紧急情况的概念。它们就像宪法中随处可见的这种“遇紧急情况拉响警报”的东西。他们对于制定某种把国会手脚绑得太紧的规则感到紧张。是的。当然，你知道，当时设想的紧急情况是遭到入侵，在建国时期，这就像是一个严重的威胁和关切。我想，你知道的，他们绝不会想到会有一个总统将移民问题当作紧急情况来使用，以此来说，嗯，这就是为什么我们可以不经指控或不让其诉诸法庭就拘留人们。
That's, you know, that's the novel version. And you're right, the scarier version. Yeah, yeah, they would not have contemplated that. They were really thinking about British troops landing on a shore and, like, not having time to have trials and just, like, kicking them out if it's all fit. Or French influence, French influencers granting titles of nobility right and left. Coming up our conversation with senior senator Elizabeth Warren. And now our guest for this episode, Senator Elizabeth Warren. Senator Warren has represented Massachusetts since 2013, and she's spent a lot of time trying to set up protections for people against big banks and other corporations.
That's, you know, that's the novel version. And you're right, the scarier version. Yeah, yeah, they would not have contemplated that. They were really thinking about British troops landing on a shore and, like, not having time to have trials and just, like, kicking them out if it's all fit. Or French influence, French influencers granting titles of nobility right and left. Coming up our conversation with senior senator Elizabeth Warren. And now our guest for this episode, Senator Elizabeth Warren. Senator Warren has represented Massachusetts since 2013, and she's spent a lot of time trying to set up protections for people against big banks and other corporations.|||你知道，那是新颖的版本。你说得对，那是更可怕的版本。是的，是的，他们绝不会想到这一点。他们当时真正想到的是英国军队在海岸登陆，然后，比如，没有时间进行审判，只要合适就把他们踢出去。或者是法国的影响，法国的影响力人物到处授予贵族头衔。接下来我们将与资深参议员伊丽莎白·沃伦（Elizabeth Warren）进行对话。现在本期节目的嘉宾是参议员伊丽莎白·沃伦。自2013年以来，沃伦参议员一直代表马萨诸塞州，她花了很多时间试图为民众建立针对大银行和其他公司的保护机制。
The Senate has been the most powerful legislative body since the Constitution was ratified. just 100 people wield great influence over what can and can't happen in this country. Through most of its history, the U.S. Senate has worked to slow down and temper the change demanded by the lower house and the president, both for good and for ill. One of the hallmarks of the Senate is that they vigorously defend their role as the wise, elder decision makers of the country. But lately, Republican senators have seemed happy to give over much of their power to the executive branch under President Trump, and that is troubling to people like Democratic Senator Elizabeth Warren. Just a note, we spoke with the Senator in mid-September before the shutdown started. So when we talk about it, we discuss the shutdown as an impending possibility.
The Senate has been the most powerful legislative body since the Constitution was ratified. just 100 people wield great influence over what can and can't happen in this country. Through most of its history, the U.S. Senate has worked to slow down and temper the change demanded by the lower house and the president, both for good and for ill. One of the hallmarks of the Senate is that they vigorously defend their role as the wise, elder decision makers of the country. But lately, Republican senators have seemed happy to give over much of their power to the executive branch under President Trump, and that is troubling to people like Democratic Senator Elizabeth Warren. Just a note, we spoke with the Senator in mid-September before the shutdown started. So when we talk about it, we discuss the shutdown as an impending possibility.|||自宪法批准以来，参议院一直是权力最大的立法机构。仅仅100人就在这个国家能发生什么和不能发生什么的事情上发挥着巨大的影响力。在其大部分历史中，美国参议院一直致力于放慢和缓和下议院和总统所要求的变革，无论是好是坏。参议院的标志之一是，他们极力捍卫自己作为这个国家明智的长者决策者的角色。但最近，共和党参议员似乎很乐意将他们的大部分权力移交给特朗普总统领导下的行政部门，这让民主党参议员伊丽莎白·沃伦这样的人感到不安。顺便说明一下，我们在9月中旬政府关门开始之前与这位参议员进行了交谈。因此，当我们谈论此事时，我们是将政府关门视为一种迫在眉睫的可能性来讨论的。
Senator Warren, thanks so much for being on the show. Oh, thank you for having me. I'm excited to do this. So happy to have you. Much of your job description is contained in Article 1, sections 8 and 9, which sets out the powers of Congress, what Congress can and can't do. Which of these powers do you wish people had a better understanding of? Well, it's that Congress makes the laws.
Senator Warren, thanks so much for being on the show. Oh, thank you for having me. I'm excited to do this. So happy to have you. Much of your job description is contained in Article 1, sections 8 and 9, which sets out the powers of Congress, what Congress can and can't and can't do. Which of these powers do you wish people had a better understanding of? Well, it's that Congress makes the laws.|||沃伦参议员，非常感谢您参加本节目。哦，谢谢邀请我。我很兴奋能参加。很高兴有您作客。您的大部分工作职责都包含在第一条第八款和第九款中，其中规定了国会的权力，即国会能做什么和不能做什么。在这些权力中，您希望人们对哪一项有更好的理解？嗯，那就是国会制定法律。
And that's our job. This is what I'm just, I go around all day doing Article I stuff, which is working on the laws. And when I say that it's, you're not only past the laws themselves, you fund them and make sure there's money to get out and do those things. and raise the revenues in order to fund that work. So we're, you know, we're the branch that's supposed to do the kind of nuts and bolts. Not very sexy, but wow, is it important? And the reason I say that is not just that you get to make the laws. The point is what's happening in Article 1 is not what's happening with the President of the United States.
And that's our job. This is what I'm just, I go around all day doing Article I stuff, which is working on the laws. And when I say that it's, you're not only past the laws themselves, you fund them and make sure there's money to get out and do those things. and raise the revenues in order to fund that work. So we're, you know, we're the branch that's supposed to do the kind of nuts and bolts. Not very sexy, but wow, is it important? And the reason I say that is not just that you get to make the laws. The point is what's happening in Article 1 is not what's happening with the President of the United States.|||这就是我们的工作。这就是我整天在做的事情，我整天都在处理第一条的事情，也就是致力于法律工作。当我这么说的时候，不仅是说你要通过法律本身，你还要为它们提供资金，确保有钱拿出去做那些事情，并筹集税收来为这项工作提供资金。所以我们，你知道的，我们是应该负责那些基础琐事的部门。虽然不是很吸引眼球，但天哪，它太重要了！我这么说不仅仅是因为你可以制定法律。关键在于，第一条中发生的事情与美国总统正在做的事情截然不同。
It's the separation here. And I know people talk all the time about separation of powers and so, but this is really a big deal because this is about, this is like if you had to start with your reading of the Constitution, king, no king, it's Article 1 that starts us with no king because the president of the United States does not get the magic wand, which he can then wave over the rest of the country. and say, okay, here's the deal. Highways over here, millions of dollars over there to build a military base. So for me, that's kind of the heart of the job. It's not only what we do to make laws, it's that we underscore three times over here in Congress are the ones who are supposed to make the laws. The president gets to check us by vetoing him if he doesn't like it.
It's the separation here. And I know people talk all the time about separation of powers and so, but this is really a big deal because this is about, this is like if you had to start with your reading of the Constitution, king, no king, it's Article 1 that starts us with no king because the president of the United States does not get the magic wand, which he can then wave over the rest of the country. and say, okay, here's the deal. Highways over here, millions of dollars over there to build a military base. So for me, that's kind of the heart of the job. It's not only what we do to make laws, it's that we underscore three times over here in Congress are the ones who are supposed to make the laws. The president gets to check us by vetoing him if he doesn't like it.|||这里的关键在于分权。我知道人们总是在谈论三权分立等等，但这真的是一件大事，因为这关乎——这就好比如果你从阅读宪法开始：国王还是没有国王？正是第一条让我们以“没有国王”开局，因为美国总统没有魔杖，他不能挥舞着魔杖对全国其他地方说：“好吧，就这样定了。高速公路建在这边，几百万美元拿去那边建军事基地。”所以对我和这份工作来说，这正是工作的核心所在。这不仅关乎我们为制定法律所做的事情，还关乎我们在这里三令五申：国会才是应该制定法律的人。如果总统不喜欢，他可以通过行使否决权来制衡我们。
He can veto the budget. But even that, we can override him if our numbers are big. enough to do that. So to me, that's the heart of the game. So this power of the purse is sort of like the primary power of Congress. How is that being tested right now in this administration? Oh, you heard me inhale. Well, and you heard me inhale because, frankly, it's never been tested like this before. I mean, you know, there's been a little nibbling around the edge when the president says, well, I don't want to do that. and, you know, there's been a little back and forth, but whoa, way out at the margins and
He can veto the budget. But even that, we can override him if our numbers are big. enough to do that. So to me, that's the game. So this power of the purse is sort of like the primary power of Congress. How is that being tested right now in this administration? Oh, you heard me inhale. Well, and you heard me inhale because, frankly, it's never been tested like this before. I mean, you know, there's been a little nibbling around the edge when the president says, well, I don't want to do that. and, you know, there's been a little back and forth, but whoa, way out at the margins and|||他可以否决预算。但即便如此，如果我们的人数足够多，我们仍然可以推翻他的否决。所以对我来说，这就是核心机制。因此，这种“钱袋子”权力有点像是国会的核心权力。在当前的这一届政府中，这项权力正受到怎样的考验？哦，你听到我倒吸了一口气吧。嗯，你听到我倒吸了一口气，因为坦率地说，它以前从未受到过这样的考验。我的意思是，你知道的，过去当总统说“嗯，我不想这么做”时，边缘地带可能会有一些小摩擦，你知道的，会有一些来来回回的争论，但是，哇，那完全是在边缘和
fringes. And instead, what's happening right now is, let me just give a very specific example. Please. Congress, Congress, triple underline, said, here's the money we're going to put into foreign aid, and we're going to give it to USAID. And we even got really specific about that. And we said, you know, here's money we want to put into foreign aid. vaccinating little children in other countries who face terrible disease. Here's money we want to
fringes. And instead, what's happening right now is, let me just give a very specific example. Please. Congress, Congress, triple underline, said, here's the money we're going to put into foreign aid, and we're going to give it to USAID. And we even got really specific about that. And we said, you know, here's money we want to put into foreign aid. vaccinating little children in other countries who face terrible disease. Here's money we want to|||边缘地带。相反，现在正在发生的事情是——请允许我举一个非常具体的例子。请讲。国会，国会（这里要画三条下划线），明确表示：这是我们要投入到对外援助中的资金，我们将把它交给美国国际开发署（USAID）。我们甚至对此进行了非常具体的规定。我们说，你知道的，这是我们想要投入到对外援助中的资金，用于为其他面临可怕疾病的小孩接种疫苗。这是我们想要投入的资金……
put in to food support in places where there's starvation. And we have a lot of, just a little background here, there's a lot of policy, really interesting policy discussions behind it, because it's often things like our own military will say, boy, they need some help over here because starvation is what's causing people to turn to the terrorists, because the terrorists have gotten financing and can help feed people. So please put more money in so that we can get them over with the good guys. Why it is that we fund schools in places like Afghanistan. You know, so when the pieces often fit together and they're often between Democrats and Republicans highly contested sounds a little too cranky, but it's the basic idea. As well, how much do you want for
put in to food support in places where there's starvation. And we have a lot of, just a little background here, there's a lot of policy, really interesting policy discussions behind it, because it's often things like our own military will say, boy, they need some help over here because starvation is what's causing people to turn to the terrorists, because the terrorists have gotten financing and can help feed people. So please put more money in so that we can get them over with the good guys. Why it is that we fund schools in places like Afghanistan. You know, so when the pieces often fit together and they're often between Democrats and Republicans highly contested sounds a little too cranky, but it's the basic idea. As well, how much do you want for|||……用于在存在饥荒的地方提供粮食支援。我们有很多——这里做一点背景介绍——这背后有很多政策，非常有趣的政策讨论，因为这往往涉及到这样的事情：我们自己的军方会说，“天哪，他们这边需要一些帮助，因为饥荒正是导致人们转向恐怖分子的原因，因为恐怖分子得到了资金支持，能够帮助养活人们。所以请投入更多的资金，这样我们就能把他们拉拢到好人这边来。”这就是为什么我们在阿富汗等地资助学校。你知道的，当这些碎片拼凑在一起时，它们往往在民主党和共和党之间引起激烈的争论——听起来可能有点古怪，但这正是基本思路。还有，你想要多少钱用于……
that. Well, I want more for that. Well, okay, if I give you more for that, will you give me something over here or stop doing this other thing? And I say Republicans and Democrats, I really want to be fair here. Not all Democrats agree with each other. Not all Republicans agree with each other. So this is a real sausage-making moment. And so all of that is by way of saying last year, Congress said, here's how much money we want to make sure goes into USAID, aid around the world. And relative to our budget is really small, but really important. And a lot of good people made the case for why that money needed to go to fight off Ebola so it doesn't come to the United States. You get the idea. Yeah. Donald Trump comes in with Elon Musk and the golden
that. Well, I want more for that. Well, okay, if I give you more for that, will you give me something over here or stop doing this other thing? And I say Democrats and Republicans, I really want to be fair here. Not all Democrats agree with each other. Not all Republicans agree with each other. So this is a real sausage-making moment. And so all of that is by way of saying last year, Congress said, here's how much money we want to make sure goes into USAID, aid around the world. And relative to our budget is really small, but really important. And a lot of good people made the case for why that money needed to go to fight off Ebola so it doesn't come to the United States. You get the idea. Yeah. Donald Trump comes in with Elon Musk and the golden|||……那个？嗯，我希望那个项目多拿点。好吧，如果我同意那个项目多给你点，你能不能在边上给我点补偿，或者停止做另一件事？当我说民主党和共和党时，我真的很想做到公平。并不是所有民主党人都意见一致。并不是所有共和党人都意见一致。所以这是一个真正的“制作香肠”（利益妥协）的时刻。所有这些都是为了说明：去年，国会表示，这是我们希望确保投入到美国国际开发署以及全球援助中的资金数额。相对于我们的预算来说，这笔钱真的很小，但真的非常重要。许多优秀的人士论证了为什么这笔钱必须用于抗击埃博拉病毒，以防它蔓延到美国。你懂这个意思。是的。唐纳德·特朗普带着埃隆·马斯克以及金色的……
and chainsaw and just says, nope, I'm not going to spend it. We're just, we're going to padlock this agency, literally take down the sign in front, stop, and they put something called a stop work order, which, which doesn't just say, spend the money you've already got, roll this stuff on it. It literally said, don't touch this stuff. And food that we had spent to starving people. Some of it ends up rotting on docks where it got unloaded. Medications that needed to be distributed were just left. I heard from one of my Republican colleagues that a bunch of arms, guns, weapons, ammunition that had been seized from potential terrorists and groups overseas. We just walked away from guard. We just walked away from
and chainsaw and just says, nope, I'm not going to spend it. We're just, we're going to padlock this agency, literally take down the sign in front, stop, and they put something called a stop work order, which, which doesn't just say, spend the money you've already got, roll this stuff on it. It literally said, don't touch this stuff. And food that we had spent to starving people. Some of it ends up rotting on docks where it got unloaded. Medications that needed to be distributed were just left. I heard from one of my Republican colleagues that a bunch of arms, guns, weapons, ammunition that had been seized from potential terrorists and groups overseas. We just walked away from guard. We just walked away from|||……电锯进来了，直接说：不，我不会把钱花在这上面。我们要，我们要给这个机构加锁，字面意义上拆掉前面的招牌，停下来。他们下达了所谓的“停工令”，这项命令不仅不是说“把你们已经得到的钱花掉，把这些东西推进下去”，它字面上的意思是：别碰这些东西。我们花钱买来送给饥民的食物，其中一部分最后在卸货的码头上腐烂了。需要分发的药物被直接搁置。我从一位共和党同僚那里听说，有一批从海外潜在恐怖分子和组织那里缴获的武器、枪支、弹药，我们竟然就放弃了看守。我们直接放弃了……
guarding it and couldn't give the money to the people who were guarding it. And guess what? The guns all get picked up and redistributed. I'm going to assume to bad guys. So the question that becomes, whoa, who put a stop to that? Congress didn't put a stop to it. We didn't say, hey, that's okay. Donald Trump and Elon Musk, as his right-hand man on that, just stopped it. And if he can do that, then that whole notion that Congress decides for better and for worse, Congress decides how to spend money and what programs will get funded, suddenly is gone and we have a president who looks a whole lot more like a king than actually a president who has genuine and meaningful checks on his power.
guarding it and couldn't give the money to the people who were guarding it. And guess what? The guns all get picked up and redistributed. I'm going to assume to bad guys. So the question that becomes, whoa, who put a stop to that? Congress didn't put a stop to that. We didn't say, hey, that's okay. Donald Trump and Elon Musk, as his right-hand man on that, just stopped it. And if he can do that, then that whole notion that Congress decides for better and for worse, Congress decides how to spend money and what programs will get funded, suddenly is gone and we have a president who looks a whole lot more like a king than actually a president who has genuine and meaningful checks on his power.|||……看守，也无法把资金发给负责看守的人。你猜怎么着？这些枪支全部被捡起来重新分配了。我猜肯定是落入了坏人手中。所以问题就来了，哇，是谁叫停了这一切？国会并没有叫停这一切。我们并没有说：“嘿，没关系。”唐纳德·特朗普以及作为其在这方面得力助手的埃隆·马斯克，直接叫停了它。如果他能做到这一点，那么“无论好坏都由国会决定，国会决定如何花钱以及哪些项目获得资助”的整个概念突然就烟消云散了，我们迎来了一位看起来更像国王的总统，而不是一位权力受到真正且有意义制衡的总统。
Now, Senator, it sounds like, you know, some people may be confused because there are claims that, well, maybe there are legal ways that any president can try and take some funds, defer them or hold on to them. And yet they're also, as you describe, these big claims of power and taking and interfering with what Congress is doing. Could you explain perhaps what's going on here with President Trump? Sure. So think of it this way. Congress writes this set of rules. And it basically says, Congress is going to get some. some power. The president's going to get some power, and the president does have some power. He just
Now, Senator, it sounds like, you know, some people may be confused because there are claims that, well, maybe there are legal ways that any president can try and take some funds, defer them or hold on to them. And yet they're also, as you describe, these big claims of power and taking and interfering with what Congress is doing. Could you explain perhaps what's going on here with President Trump? Sure. So think of it this way. Congress writes this set of rules. And it basically says, Congress is going to get some. some power. The president's going to get some power, and the president does have some power. He just|||参议员，听起来，你知道的，有些人可能会感到困惑，因为有人声称，任何总统或许都有合法的途径去尝试拿走一些资金、推迟使用或扣留它们。然而正如您所描述的那样，这也伴随着对权力的巨大宣称、攫取以及对国会工作的干涉。您能否解释一下特朗普总统这里到底发生了什么？当然可以。你可以这样想：国会制定了这套规则。它基本上规定：国会将获得一些权力。总统将获得一些权力，而且总统确实拥有一些权力。他只是……
doesn't have that power. And the courts are going to get some power. They're going to get to review what the president does, make sure the president stays within the law. So it's all written on a presumption that nobody gives up power. So the whole constitution functions on this idea that Congress will jealously guard its power, the courts will jealously guard their power, and the president will jealously guard his power. What has shifted now is that it's both halves. We have a president, Donald Trump, who's saying, give me, give me, give me, you know, I want to decide where money got spent. I want to decide that this age. agency doesn't get any money and that agency only gets to do this thing and not this other
doesn't have that power. And the courts are going to get some power. They're going to get to review what the president does, make sure the president stays within the law. So it's all written on a presumption that nobody gives up power. So the whole constitution functions on this idea that Congress will jealously guard its power, the courts will jealously guard their power, and the president will jealously guard his power. What has shifted now is that it's both halves. We have a president, Donald Trump, who's saying, give me, give me, give me, you know, I want to decide where money got spent. I want to decide that this age. agency doesn't get any money and that agency only gets to do this thing and not this other|||……没有那种权力。法院也将获得一些权力。他们将审查总统的所作所为，确保总统在法律允许的范围内行事。因此，这一切都是基于“没有人会放弃权力”的假设而写成的。所以整部宪法的运作都基于这样一个理念：国会将极力捍卫其权力，法院将极力捍卫其权力，总统也将极力捍卫其权力。现在发生改变的是，双方都变了。我们有一位总统唐纳德·特朗普，他说：“给我，给我，给我，你知道的，我想决定钱花在哪里。我想决定这个机构得不到任何资金，而那个机构只能做这件事，不能做另一件事。”
thing, that Donald Trump gets to decide it all. And that only works because he has a compliant Congress saying, yes, dear leader, whatever you want to do. And that's, that's for me the horror of this moment. It's that you've got to want to be. with a spineless Congress, and that is not something, go read the Federalist Papers, that any of the folks who are drafting the Constitution ever seem to contemplate as a possibility. Right now, think of it this way, we have a Senate that is 5347, 57, 53 Democrats, Republicans, I wish, 53 Republicans, I'm a Democrat. I'm 53 Republicans, 47 Democrats.
thing, that Donald Trump gets to decide it all. And that only works because he has a compliant Congress saying, yes, dear leader, whatever you want to do. And that's, that's for me the horror of this moment. It's that you've got to want to be. with a spineless Congress, and that is not something, go read the Federalist Papers, that any of the folks who are drafting the Constitution ever seem to contemplate as a possibility. Right now, think of it this way, we have a Senate that is 5347, 57, 53 Democrats, Republicans, I wish, 53 Republicans, I'm a Democrat. I'm 53 Republicans, 47 Democrats.|||——这一切都由唐纳德·特朗普来决定。这种情况之所以能行得通，仅仅是因为他拥有一个顺从的国会，对他说：“是的，敬爱的领袖，您想做什么都行。”对我和这个时刻来说，最可怕的正是这一点。那就是你居然愿意与一个毫无骨气的国会同流合污，你去读读《联邦党人文集》，宪法的起草者们似乎从未将这视为一种可能发生的情况。现在，这样想吧，我们的参议院席位比例是53比47——53名共和党人（我希望是，我是民主党人，我是说53名共和党人，47名民主党人）。
If four Republicans in the United States Senate would say, okay, we get that you don't like some of the things that Congress allocated money for. But listen, bud, that was the deal. We engaged in a lot of negotiations. We got things that were our priorities and returned from the other side, getting some things that were their priorities. You don't get to just sit here and wave the magic wand and suddenly defund things you don't like or move money from up. I'll give you an example that came up this morning in a hearing.
If four Republicans in the United States Senate would say, okay, we get that you don't like some of the things that Congress allocated money for. But listen, bud, that was the deal. We engaged in a lot of negotiations. We got things that were our priorities and returned from the other side, getting some things that were their priorities. You don't get to just sit here and wave the magic wand and suddenly defund things you don't like or move money from up. I'll give you an example that came up this morning in a hearing.|||如果美国参议院中有四名共和党人肯站出来说：“好吧，我们明白你不喜欢国会拨款支持的一些项目。但听着，老兄，交易就是交易。我们进行了大量的谈判。我们争取到了符合我们优先事项的东西，作为回报，对方也争取到了一些符合他们优先事项的东西。你不能就这么坐在那儿挥舞魔杖，突然取消你不喜欢的项目的资金，或者把资金从……”我举一个今天上午在听证会上遇到的例子。
Move money from repairing army barracks and Marines barracks that were in terrible disrepair. You don't get to seize that money and suddenly use it down at the border to start building your wall or whatever is you want to do. with the board. You just don't get to do that under the rules of the Constitution who has what powers. If four senators would say to the press of the United States, cut this out, we're not going to do this with you. And we will not confirm a single secretary or nominee that you send over. We will not give you any more money to spend unless you knock it off. Then this moment of of attack on the Constitution would shrink way down. It wouldn't be gone entirely because you'd still have a president who'd be looking for
Move money from repairing army barracks and Marines barracks that were in terrible disrepair. You don't get to seize that money and suddenly use it down at the border to start building your wall or whatever is you want to do. with the board. You just don't get to do that under the rules of the Constitution who has what powers. If four senators would say to the press of the United States, cut this out, we're not going to do this with you. And we will not confirm a single secretary or nominee that you send over. We will not give you any more money to spend unless you knock it off. Then this moment of of attack on the Constitution would shrink way down. It wouldn't be gone entirely because you'd still have a president who'd be looking for|||将用于修缮严重失修的陆军营房和海军陆战队营房的资金挪作他用。你不能没收这笔资金，然后突然把它拿到边境去开始修建你的墙，或者你在边境想干的别的什么事。根据宪法关于谁拥有什么权力的规则，你就是不能这样做。如果有四名参议员对美国总统说：“住手吧，我们不会陪你胡闹。对于你派过来的任何一位部长或被提名人，我们都不会予以确认。除非你罢手，否则我们不会再给你一分钱花。”那么，这种对宪法的攻击时刻就会大大缩减。它不会完全消失，因为你仍然会有一位总统，他会寻找……
every opportunity to say, give me, give me, gimme, gimme, but he would now be a toddler confined to a pretty small room where he couldn't do nearly so much damage. And so that's the thing about separation of powers. It's based on the premise that each of the three. groups will defend its own power. And right now, the spineless Republicans are, they are creating a part of this constitutional crisis. Senator, you've just described a way that the Senate could provide a check on what the president is doing. And of course, President Trump has been trying to claim more and more presidential power for himself. And we've also seen that the Supreme Court has been
every opportunity to say, give me, give me, gimme, gimme, but he would now be a toddler confined to a pretty small room where he couldn't do nearly so much damage. And so that's the thing about separation of powers. It's based on the premise that each of the three. groups will defend its own power. And right now, the spineless Republicans are, they are creating a part of this constitutional crisis. Senator, you've just described a way that the Senate could provide a check on what the president is doing. And of course, President Trump has been trying to claim more and more presidential power for himself. And we've also seen that the Supreme Court has been|||每一个机会去叫喊“给我，给我，给我，给我”，但他现在只会变成一个被关在小房间里的幼儿，无法造成那么大的破坏了。这就是三权分立的真谛。它基于这样一个前提：三个部门中的每一个都会捍卫自己的权力。而现在，那些毫无骨气的共和党人正在制造这场宪法危机的一部分。参议员，您刚才描述了一种参议院可以对总统所作所为进行制衡的方式。当然，特朗普总统一直在试图为自己谋取越来越多的总统权力。我们也看到最高法院一直在……
pretty willing to grant him that power. So if Congress could or if the Senate could but isn't doing anything right now about that, could Congress realistically do something to check the Supreme Court itself? Well, this is a hard one. So let's, let's do this one kind of in steps. You know, part of the answer is it depends on what the Supreme Court says. You know, now we're going to, you and I, Elizabeth, can just be dorky law professors here for a right. Let's do it. Give me the exact language. I feel like I'm back, you know, put your finger on the exact word in the statute that you're using. To the extent that the Supreme Court says, yo, Congress didn't make clear what's happening here.
pretty willing to grant him that power. So if Congress could or if the Senate could but isn't doing anything right now about that, could Congress realistically do something to check the Supreme Court itself? Well, this is a hard one. So let's, let's do this one kind of in steps. You know, part of the answer is it depends on what the Supreme Court says. You know, now we're going to, you and I, Elizabeth, can just be dorky law professors here for a right. Let's do it. Give me the exact language. I feel like I'm back, you know, put your finger on the exact word in the statute that you're using. To the extent that the Supreme Court says, yo, Congress didn't make clear what's happening here.|||……非常愿意赋予他这种权力。因此，如果国会能够——或者说如果参议院能够但现在却对此毫无作为，那么国会有没有切实可行的办法来制衡最高法院本身呢？嗯，这是一个棘手的问题。所以让我们，让我们一步一步来探讨这个问题。你知道，部分答案取决于最高法院怎么说。你知道，现在我们——你和我，伊丽莎白，可以暂时扮演一下书呆子气的法学教授。我们来吧。把确切的条文拿出来。我感觉自己又回到了那种状态，你知道的，把手指放在你所使用的法规中的那个确切字眼上。如果最高法院说：“喂，国会并没有把这里发生的事情说清楚。”
Congress didn't specifically say that the FTC can ban non-compete clauses. So, I guess Trump and the Trump and the Trump. Trump administration can go ahead and knock all that out, right? If Congress says, okay, courts, you think we didn't make it clear? Let me hit it again and say very clearly. We always have the power to pass more laws, you know? And if you don't think we got the FTC authorization right at some point, we can step up and say more and say it again, say it more clearly, say it more aggressively.
国会并没有具体规定联邦贸易委员会可以禁止竞业限制条款。所以，我想特朗普和特朗普的——特朗普政府可以继续把这些全都取消掉，对吧？如果国会说，好吧，法庭，你们觉得我们说得不够清楚？让我再讲一遍，说得非常清楚。你知道的，我们一直都有权力通过更多的法律？而且如果你认为我们在某个时刻对联邦贸易委员会的授权没有搞对，我们可以站出来说更多，再说一遍，说得更清楚，说得更具攻击性。
And to the extent the Supreme Court is claiming that Congress has been ambiguous in something it's written, then, yes, we have the power to fix that. It may not always be realistic in a deeply divided Congress, but at least theoretically and structurally it's there. The harder one is the Supreme Court's interpretation of the Constitution. because, let's be blunt, that is the job of the Supreme Court, is to see if the president and the administration are actually following the Constitution and the law. And here's the place, I just got to say, I am very worried that the wheels started coming off a few years back over. My particular one I would pick is money in the political system. And the Supreme Court
并且，如果最高法院声称国会在其撰写的内容中一直含糊不清，那么，是的，我们有权解决这个问题。在一个严重分裂的国会中，这可能并不总是现实的，但至少在理论上和结构上它是存在的。更难的一个是最高法院对宪法的解释。因为，说得直白一点，最高法院的工作就是看总统和行政部门是否真的在遵循宪法和法律。这里有一点，我必须得说，我非常担心的是，几年前事情开始出现崩塌。我特别会挑出的一个例子是政治系统中的金钱。而最高法院
saying, well, sure. Billionaires can pump billions of dollars into elections. And there's really not much that Congress can do. I think they are wrong on the Constitution there. But it's the upcoming threat. And I, we don't know for certain where the Supreme Court will go, but there are certainly, I just think of them as the pro-king advocates who want to say, they made up this new word, the unitary executive, that would give a theoretical president who wants to wear a crown and have a magic wand would give him that crown and magic wand by saying all of the power everywhere rests with the president and Congress is the subservient branch and the courts are subservient everyone must bow to the would-be king and for me I cannot think of an idea that
则说，嗯，当然可以。亿万富翁可以向选举注入数十亿美元。而国会其实也做不了什么。我认为他们在宪法问题上是错误的。但这是一种即将到来的威胁。而且，我们无法确切知道最高法院会走向何方，但毫无疑问，我只是把他们看作是亲国王的鼓吹者，他们想要声称——他们造了这个新词，叫做单一行政权——这会给一个理论上想要戴上王冠、拿着魔杖的总统赋予王冠和魔杖，方法是声称所有地方的所有权力都属于总统，国会是从属部门，法院也是从属部门，所有人都必须向未来的国王叩首。对我来说，我想不出还有什么想法
is more the opposite of what the Constitution says and what the history of the Constitution was all about. And I say that with a certain passion as the senator from Massachusetts, where in 1773, the good folks of Boston said, we don't want a king telling us we have to pay this tax on tea. And come on, just among my friends, wasn't a huge tax, you know, it wasn't like the king was actually
比这更完全背离宪法的宗旨以及宪法历史的初衷了。我作为马萨诸塞州的参议员，带着某种激情说出这番话，1773年，波士顿的善良民众说，我们不希望有个国王告诉我们必须缴纳这笔茶税。拜托，在朋友们之间说，这其实不是一项很重的税，你知道的，这并不是说国王真的
showing up at your house and, you know, grabbing your teapot and your pillowcases, you know, but we said, as a matter of principle, you want to tax us, you got to let us have a say in how those laws are written. Does it sound reminiscent?
会出现在你家里，然后，你知道的，拿走你的茶壶和枕套，你知道的，但我们说，出于原则问题，你们想要向我们征税，就必须让我们在这些法律是如何制定的方面拥有发言权。听起来是不是很耳熟？
You've got to let us have. We didn't call it this at the point, an Article 1, a place where the people are represented and where we get to say, this is how we want to spend money, these are the laws we want to see carried through. And, you know, we felt so strongly about that, that we dumped that British tea in the harbor. And a lot of people don't remember. We suffered consequences from that. They blockaded the harbor. And there was a lot of privation. that came from that. A lot of people. We also, at the time, evidently, the folks of messages learned to drink coffee. So, you know, a lot of things had happened from these. But this is kind of
你们必须让我们拥有。我们当时不叫这个名字，而是第一条（Article 1），一个人民拥有代表权的地方，一个我们可以说这就是我们想要如何花钱、这些就是我们希望看到得以实施的法律的地方。而且，你知道的，我们对此深信不疑，以至于我们把英国茶倒进了港口。很多人都不记得了。我们因此承受了后果。他们封锁了港口。并且因此带来了很多的艰难困苦。很多人。而且在当时，显然，马萨诸塞的民众学会了喝咖啡。所以，你知道的，由此发生了很多事情。但这也是
the precursor to the American Revolution. It's all thought around this central question. Is there one king who, from whom all things flow? Or is there a legislature? That's our article one that says, nope, you guys over here representing the eastern states and the western states, representing wigs and representing, you know, all kinds of different groups and different interests, representing rich people and poor people and farmers and urban dwellers. You will decide what the laws are, how much money is spent, and then ultimately, it's a little later on. obviously we get the amendment in, and how to raise more money to be able to support all of that. And right now, Donald Trump wants to take that away.
美国革命的前奏。这一切都是围绕着这个核心问题展开的。是否有一个唯一的国王，万物皆由他衍生？还是有一个立法机构？这就是我们的第一条，它说，不，你们这些代表东方各州和西方各州的人，代表辉格党人以及代表，你知道的，各种不同群体和不同利益的人，代表富人和穷人、农民和城市居民的人。你们将决定法律是什么，花费多少资金，然后最终，这稍微晚一点。显而易见，我们加入了修正案，以及如何筹集更多资金来支持所有这一切。而现在，唐纳德·特朗普想要夺走这一切。
And the idea here, he and he alone will decide where money gets spent. And if that is the case, we just don't have that same constitution and that same separation of powers. that since the Constitution was adopted in 1787 has been our guiding principle. So, you know, there are procedural things and there are sort of unprocedural things that are happening here. I mean, in one instance, the sort of impoundment control act leading to a rescission. And a lot of these, you know, this rescinding of money, the Rescissions Act of 2025, I mean, that was the process in a way for it to work. Is that the process failing or is that the sort of the complicity of, you know, Republicans inside of Congress doing Trump's bidding? Right. It's the complicity of Republicans who evidently are more afraid of Trump than they are the people who elected them to the Senate and to the House.
这里的核心思想是，只有他一个人来决定资金花在什么地方。如果真是这样，我们就失去了自1787年宪法通过以来一直作为我们指导原则的那个宪法以及那种三权分立体制。所以，你知道的，这里正在发生一些程序性的事情，也有一些非程序性的事情。我的意思是，在某种情况下，比如导致撤回资金的扣留资金控制法案。这里有许多这样的，你知道的，撤回资金的做法，即2025年撤回拨款法案，我的意思是，在某种程度上这也是它运作的程序。这是程序的失效，还是说，你知道的，国会内部的共和党人同流合污、听命于特朗普？没错。这就是那些共和党人的同流合污，他们显然对特朗普的恐惧超过了对选他们进入参众两院的人民的恐惧。
And look, we're about to face this. I'm not going to reverse it on you because the place, well, the place we're about to face this. is there's a budget that has to be passed. Funding runs out for the government. So this is kind of the other half of how this works. So come September 30th, just a couple of weeks from now, the government runs out of money. And Congress is the only one who can authorize more money going forward. That's, again, right there in Article 1. So the Republicans who have been entirely spineless on holding Donald Trump accountable to spend the money that they had allocated are now in the business of trying to negotiate with Democrats for a budget, and we're all in the shadow of, whoa, let me understand this. We're negotiating for a budget, and yet if we get into
听着，我们马上就要面对这一点了。我不会对你隐瞒，因为这个地方，嗯，我们即将面对这个地方的情况是，有一份预算必须通过。政府的资金快用完了。所以这是这种运作机制的另一半。因此，到了9月30日，也就是从现在算起的几周后，政府的资金就要耗尽了。而国会是唯一能够授权未来提供更多资金的机构。这一点，再次强调，就写在第一条里。因此，那些在迫使唐纳德·特朗普按照他们拨款的额度花钱这件事情上毫无骨气的共和党人，现在正忙着试图与民主党人就预算进行谈判，而我们都笼罩在这样一种阴影之下：哇，让我理清一下。我们正在为预算进行谈判，然而如果我们陷入
this budget, more funding for health care, something we fight for is Democrat, more funding for child care, something I keep fighting for, right? We fight for those things, and you guys say, yeah, sure, we'll give it to you. And then we all sign off on it. We all vote for it. And then Donald Trump signs it into law. Yay. And the next day, said, God, I can't believe how done those people are. We're not going to put that money into health care. We're not going to put that money into child care. So that is the context in which these negotiations are taking place right now. And that's why, over the next couple of weeks, You may hear people talking about, so what exactly are the parties negotiating for?
这个预算之中，为医疗保健争取更多资金——这是我们作为民主党人一直在争取的东西，为儿童保育争取更多资金——这是我一直在争取的东西，对吧？我们为这些事情奋斗，而你们这些家伙说，行，没问题，我们会给你们的。然后我们所有人都签署同意了。我们所有人都投票赞成了。接着唐纳德·特朗普将其签署为法律。太棒了。而第二天，他说，天哪，我真不敢相信那些人怎么这么蠢。我们不会把这笔钱投入医疗保健。我们不会把这笔钱投入儿童保育。所以，这就是目前正在进行这些谈判的背景。这就是为什么在接下来的几周里，你会听到人们讨论：那么两党到底在为什么而谈判？
What are the things they're fighting over? And for a big one, for Democrats, it's going to be get rid of these terrible health care cuts that the Trump administration and the Republicans have forced through. We want a lower cause for American families. We want to get some things into the budget for that. And we want some kind of reassuring. other than, yeah, yeah, that Donald Trump is not going to pull this same thing over and over and just pick the things we like and negotiated for and defund those.
他们争论的焦点是什么？对于民主党人来说，其中一个重大的焦点将是摆脱特朗普政府和共和党人强行通过的这些可怕的医疗保健削减。我们希望为美国家庭降低成本。我们希望在预算中为此争取一些东西。并且我们想要某种形式的保证。除了那些——对对，唐纳德·特朗普不会一遍又一遍地搞这一套，把我们喜欢并已经谈妥的东西挑出来，然后取消它们的资金。
Senator Warren, thank you so much for your time and talk to us about the Article 1 of the Constitution. I really appreciate it. We're so happy to have you. Thank you so much for having me. What a great conversation. Let's do it again if you have other articles. Oh, please. I love that.
沃伦参议员，非常感谢您抽出时间与我们谈论宪法第一条。我真的非常感激。我们非常高兴邀请到您。非常感谢邀请我。这是一次极好的对话。如果您还有其他文章，我们再来一次！哦，拜访吧。我喜欢这样。
Welcome back anytime. All right, take care. Join us next month, we're tackling Article 2, which establishes the executive branch of the government. That will be interesting and relevant. Don't miss it. The 99% of visible breakdown of the Constitution is produced by Isabel Angel, edited by committee, music by Swan Real, mixed by Martine Gonzalez.
欢迎随时回来。好的，保重。下个月请继续收听我们节目，我们将探讨第二条，该条确立了政府的行政分支。那将非常有趣且切合时宜。千万不要错过。《宪法无处不在》（99% Invisible）由伊莎贝尔·安杰尔（Isabel Angel）制作，委员会剪辑，天鹅真实（Swan Real）配乐，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）混音。
99% of Visible's executive producer is Kathy 2. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashma Don, Jacob Medina Gleason, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor.
《宪法无处不在》的执行制片人是凯茜·图（Kathy Tu）。我们的资深编辑是德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）。库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·莱（Vivian Lay）、拉什马·唐（Lashma Don）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森（Jacob Medina Gleason）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《宪法无处不在》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）设计。本系列的美术作品由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）创作。
We are a part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show on all the usual social media sites as well as their own Discord server. We have lots of fun discussion about constitutional law, about architecture, about movies, about music, all kinds of good stuff. You can find a link to the Discord server as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分，现在总部位于潘多拉大厦向北六个街区的地方。位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及他们自己的Discord服务器上找到这个节目。我们针对宪法、建筑、电影、音乐以及各种好东西进行了许多有趣的讨论。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到 Discord 服务器的链接以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。